i'm not going to share who i am as an
artist as a creator as a writer
i'm going to put out a blind query
letter with a log line etc
and i'll send it to a stranger who does
not yet know me
and i'm going to hope and pray
to get a good response
is hollywood a game gary
in a sense yes
i suppose but i think life in a way is a
game like it's in in the best sense
um
but you sort of have to understand the
rules of it
um
people talk about breaking into
hollywood
which i always find fascinating um
because life is not an event it's a
process right and
i think
when people think about you know people
people are very given to stories in
their craft and
their dream of what it is they want to
accomplish
we know at show business but very few
people really think about the business
side of the equation
and
i find a lot of creatives in particular
are
not intentionally random but they are
they end up being random in their
approach
focusing on craft not thinking about how
they're going to navigate
as if
our industry is somehow different from
all other industries
uh which it's not
i mean it it is in a sense but it's
not in the sense of being relationship
based
um
and i i you know what what i would
encourage people is i i try and train
people to be hyper focused hyper
intentional
radically transparent and
not
think about needing a representative so
much as being themselves a presence
developing rapport creating
relationships in this business
and understanding that the first thing
they have to know is who are you
who are you in the world what do you
care about what
what's your creative dna what's your
signature what what are the kinds of
stories you want to be participating in
or writing or directing or producing
whatever it might be
and then thinking about
if that's true
who is it that i really need to know if
hypothetically if i could have a hundred
people
over time
be my champions and mentors who would
they be
and that's going to be different from me
to the person sitting next to me
and then making that reality come to
come to be
right i think a lot of a lot of people
are taught unfortunate habits
so
[Music]
they learn they mimic habits of of their
peers which may or may not be optimal
writers may for example send upline
query letters that are deeply impersonal
and fly into strangers in boxes asking
them to either produce it or represent
them or whatever it might be a big ask
as opposed to humanizing the process
over and again time and time again i get
the sense that people people have a
story that hollywood is not welcoming
that it's
um that they have they don't understand
their value and they don't know that the
welcome mat is out
which couldn't be further from the truth
if you approach people the way you would
in any other environment
so what i
wish for people is
that they get more comfortable being
vulnerable and telling people what's
unique about them why who are they
what's what's what's some any one really
delicious unexpected
uh nugget from their life experience
that makes them memorable
tell people share with people
what was why was this particular of all
the possible stories in the universe why
this one
what's the connective tissue why was
that so important to you that you put
all your soul equity into creating this
and
a third leg of this school very
important is
don't just send it out randomly
if i want to send you this project
why you why have i chosen you
not because your name was in a directory
i researched you there was some one film
that you made perhaps that was
um like i got sucker punched in the
third eye it's so spot on or maybe it's
your entire body of work
there's
something that called me to think you
might be a right size fit a good match
for me and for this particular story
say those things pick up the phone
don't rely on social media don't rely on
blind query letters make it personal
this is a personal business
reach out to someone and do not be a
snob you're not going to probably reach
the name on the door
nor do you necessarily need
to i've always learned i built my entire
career based on one simple realization
early on
all i need to do is befriend the
assistant
the assistant or of any you know when
assistants move on they go to
the next little notch up which is still
entry level it's creative executive it's
a director
production it's a you know
head of development whatever their
titles
all of those people beginning with the
person who answers the phone which is
usually an assistant
these
are your target these are the people who
have enormous value
who are so aligned with you
you have so much in common with them
they are highly vetted
they are
usually like they beat out 50 people or
more to get that particular perch
they're ambitious they're sitting on the
inside learning the business
on a producer's desk or an agent's desk
or whatever it might be casting studio
and they are
going to last in that position for 18 24
some number of months
and they will matriculate
because they're really good
and they've had to work really hard and
and you know that's their sharpening
stone
these people need relationships with you
as much as you need one with them
and
most people don't understand that it's
like the currency of most of us is who's
what relationships do i enjoy with
talent in front of the camera behind the
camera it doesn't matter
do i know other good producers writers
cinematographers actors whatever it
might be casting directors
we're all in the business of
relationship
and so
it's a beautiful game of human failures
and everyone is instead of being narrow
focused and saying i'm just going to
i'm not going to share who i am as an
artist as a creator as a writer
i'm going to put out a blind query
letter with a log line etc and i'll send
it to a stranger who does not yet know
me
and i'm going to hope and pray
to get a good response
and
the common refrain is
not a positive response
i send out hundreds i get two responses
there usually passes
very typical
as opposed to saying i'm going to dare
to be uncomfortable and awkward for a
moment
i'm going to take a minor risk it's not
threatening my life but i'm going to
take a minor risk of being uncomfortable
and i'm going to call someone who does
not know me
and i'm going to introduce myself and
i'm not going to ask a big favor
the first couple of calls i'm only going
to ask advice it's gonna that's what i
learned early on is like make everyone
your mentor
ask advice keep the call to three four
minutes
do it again a week later
make a friend
and they're as desirous of that as you
are
you just have to catch them when they're
not overwhelmed
um
so i think i think you know it it's a
funny word is hollywood a game
and i think yeah if you want to win at
this if you really want to have a
viable sustainable career as a creative
what's interesting is the artist
you all you know everyone has more than
one story one hopes
um and the story may be brilliant but
what makes it really interesting is the
point of view of the creator
and why they did it and what's their
life experience we
we react to one another we are attracted
to that
and even if someone falls in love with
one of your scripts
they're never going to go forward with
it and lessen until they meet you
the creator
so i think i think in a sense you know
it's it's really
having that sort of divine inspiration
that just comes down and gives you the
permission like oh my gosh i don't need
permission i can just reach out
and talk to whoever i want no one is
unreachable
that was my earliest lesson
no one is unreachable
if you're humble if you're vulnerable if
you're if if you make it pleasant you're
you know and you can say to someone
oh my gosh i'm terrified i'm so nervous
to be calling you
even to an assistant
because it's true as long as it's true
um
but the more you
[Music]
let yourself be known
and the more other focused you become
[Music]
the more generous you are the more you
share and ask questions that are like
of human you know truly interesting to
humans
it's it works magic
if you win over an assistant and i know
i'm rambling on but if you went over an
assistant
you went over everybody in that office
because they have the full trust of
everyone in that office they've been
hired
relied on they're a critical part of the
of that mission
um if you want to win over an aw you
know a group of people get to know their
assistant
so it is a game in some sense
and to get in the game
you find that one assistant
person that's there before everyone else
maybe making coffee
getting it ready answering the phones
how do you do it in a way that's genuine
well the question is the answer
by being genuine
and saying you know i when i was new
i would just turn to people and say
i'm new
i'm the turnip that just fall off the
truck
but i'm really committed to making it in
this business but i know how much i
don't know
i have a couple of questions if you
could spend three minutes
answering my questions it would mean the
world to me
people can't resist the truth
if it's real if it's genuine
when i would call assistance
of course you don't know who they are
it's just a person answering the phone
and i would just introduce myself and
say look this is and it's what i was
talking about earlier
i am an aspiring screenwriter or fill in
the blank
i am
absolutely mesmerized by the work your
company consistently puts out into the
world
that's why i'm reaching out
and yes i have a project that's very
much that shares a lot of kinship with
the kinds of projects stories that you
tell
but i'm not sending it to you i'm not
asking you to read my script
i just want to establish
a relationship with you
and i get their name so that i can when
i'm off the call research them and find
out all sorts of delicious stuff about
them
online
um
and i will have a question or two and
it's usually
something i know they can answer it's it
might be you know how do you operate as
a company are you you know i'm not going
to send you my script but do you accept
outside material it could be
uh were you there at the time they made
this last film that came out in march
that was just so phenomenal
how did you get to be there how did how
did you get to work for this
extraordinary company
and where do you want to go
i mean i know you don't want you know
you're you're paying dues you're
sitting in the crosshairs of this
amazing opportunity
but where do you see yourself in a few
years
um
you know where'd you go to school
did you go to film school
i'll ask any question that comes up in
the moment for me
but there but there'll be questions to
which i really do want the answer it'll
be it'll help inform me about this
person
and i always build in and say look you
know i've used up my four minutes you've
been amazingly kind
to take my call
i just want you to know i really
appreciate it and i have another
question i'm thinking about a couple of
things but i'd like you know what
you're busy
i'm you know i'm going to let you go
but i'm going to call you a week from
today
if you have three or five minutes
available that would be absolutely
extraordinary
but thank you
i researched the heck out of them i
called them back the next week exactly
when i said i would
and if they're available great and if
they're not
i call back again
my idea is that people are very
welcoming
if that's your expectation that's
probably going to be the reality
if you welcome that it can be a very
welcoming experience
i don't mind people sending me query
letters but i'll tell you there's
universe galaxy of difference between if
someone sends me a query letter and i've
never spoken i have no idea who they are
and they're sending me a storyline
with the goal of me reading it and
possibly producing it or whatever their
intention is
um
versus
someone who's reached out to either me
or someone on my team
making themselves known as a human
developing some rapport
taking the time investing
a multiple of calls over the course of a
month let's say
and now they're really familiar with
someone on my team
and that person and this happens all the
time
whether it was as a manager or as a
producer someone would come to me and
say you know i've met so and so and
they're really nice
i think they're really smart and i've
just read some of their work because you
do that after three or four calls now
the the the welcome mat is out
would you take a look at it
my answer is always yes
that's
that's my team member
you know and and and
that's kind of the reality now it might
not be direct to me it might be to my
head of development or it might be some
but that's how you penetrate that's how
you get welcomed in
a query letter after you've spoken with
a human that's addressed to the human
you spoke to
is a totally different experience
than just a strange peach unexpected
email coming into my inbox or someone
else you know why why is it coming into
my inbox
and i that's not to be that's not hubris
it's just pragmatism
there are so many ways
to play the long game
build rapport
with the faith that the long game is
actually the faster track
you